Hi Felix
Konnichiwa Everyone(lOl)
It's me another day... Jesus Christ!
Another day another video just cuz I'm out traveling
Doesn't mean the videos stop
I know... that's why we had this amazing new set up that is not close to close-up at all
This is nice and intimate aren't you enjoying this? (no)
STREAM FAILS(BITCH)
That's what we're talking about today
I never done one(HELL YEAH), so I can't really relate to what we're about to witness in this video. Good joke, Felix
But here are some epic stream fails of not just people making mistakes
but getting trolled epic style by the viewers which again
I cannot relate to cause I've never been trolled by the viewers. I am just too smart for that
It just not happen and I want to start this off with
the reason why I'm making this video because it's my favorite clip of all time
I laugh just thinking about it poor innocent girl. Just wanted to play Minecraft. I couldn't find a better quality
Why is it so bad? And someone in the chat; I can't believe how you could sink this low. It's super worthwhile
Hold the pickaxe look at lava push Q
Someone comments: It's super worthwhile.
Look at lava and press Q. Okay
Oh
Poor pickaxe she threw it right into the lava. This is so sad
But wait, it gets better
Okay
why it only works with oh, I'm so I'm so
Stupid so the person comments again
I can only imagine I don't see the chat it only works with diamond pickaxe.
The first pickaxe you sent into the lava
That's too cheap. You need to throw in the
another one :V
You gotta you gotta appreciate when you acknowledge that you're really stupid and then you do something even more stupid
Now I don't afford this girl. I would do the same thing to be honest
if I wasn't so goddamn smart never I have I been troll and Winnie the Pooh if Tigger was black
What would okay. Alright, shout out to my boy. Nicky gears. Oh my god, Jesus Christ Felix
What are you doing? Read this message? I'm forcing it. Stop singing
Why did I fall for that?
Jesus Christ you could get a third person with keel just don't do on the horse. It's a bit buggy
Just don't do it on the horse in console. It's a bit buggy, press Q in the console
How could you be so stupid
I would never fall for something like that. This is the reason I don't live stream this
Don't do it on the horse. It's a bit buggy. Well played
Yeah, I guess my dick see wreck. What's up?
It's funny when they realize right after
What's up, my bro? I just shat my pants. Let's get this bread guys!
Aww Dammit
Like Dixie or something
You gonna do that... Old art do a special attack hold our do special attack it resets the game Jesus Christ
Is such a dick move.
Oh my god!
I kind of want to just make a game
for treamers and have one button that  just flips *bass* everything up
Why is it funny? It's really not funny, but it's also hilarious
=))))))))))
Huge huge load of sick
My mom's here. No can't you sub another day some another day?
Load of seamen. They don't got it. Mom. I
Don't know who that is
There's this some troll
Just having to explain that to your mom as well that just makes it 10 times better. Oh, is this huge nog?
Can you imagine having that conversation with your mom? Just sub another day, please god. Damn
I can't tell if this is one of the things would I just meet think
Think it's funny or not
Just because I can see myself in this
situation and it would actually happen to me and it is the only reason I don't scream anymore because I'm just getting cybernetically bullied just
Kidding. Okay, I would never fall for your foul tricks these bunny fools. I
Swallow, come come great
How did I poke
The
Thing is like you're streaming. It's so hard to it's so hard to be streamer gay
You just don't understand but your your focus is so shifted on so many things already like it's not just a game
But also the chat and trying to understand what is happening really got to be good at multitasking
So then when people catch you off guard with that kind of mess I get it, okay
Hey, look, it's forsen
space ah
You fool for seven
What's happening
Precious space proceeds to masturbate what the fuck Sarah there is no donation
That there's no he already raised it. What are you saying? It's out donation. There re subs tiger harvest
Thank you for your sob gully lord. Thank you for your five months
Crispy, thank you for your four months Travie. Oh man. Thank you for your six dollars. I'm tim, son
I don't notice anything Mike Hawk Meredith
Shut up to my dick
Just want to interrupt this video and give a huge shout-out to my pothole. I love woody doesn't register either. It's equally funny and
No one
no, don't do it g4 for
Some chunks why he doesn't work. Oh
God oh no three zeroes in 1g. Oh
And
1g
Do your y'all's codes are fuck busted make sure you're typing the right thing dude oh
I
Don't know I feel about this not a third time, please
Try X please
This is a great compilation by the way, I'm sure every Chad there's gonna be like, I already saw this video
I know but it's funny. Okay
His vent ro it's about hold on mutters like that's the song you like
She says she says oh my goddess
I hate that goddamn sound. I hate that goddamn sound
Smash like if you got trolled as well, let me know so I know who's a headphone user and
Smash like twice if you have the razor PewDiePie it falls just so I can know if you're a headphone razor be the PI user
God, damn, why ever did that two questions this time?
One of those medical related and the other ones not which one do you want? First the non one first, let's know that
Is just me
Talking. Yeah, does it smell like what? Oh, no dog
Dr. Murphy, please. Yep. What's that?
Sorry, what's up, dog?
Why is up dog funny
It's the lamest joke of all times and lamest dad you ever crafted you get hit by an up dog?
You might as well just end your career right there
Please be quiet and dedicate 30 seconds to his favorite 30 seconds. No take off your head. That's nice for a 30-second silence
Oh
My god, they said only use me blade the mud them were afraid to guy that only uses is played
You guys remember those days or is it just me? Okay sips
I'd just like to say I appreciate
Everything you do and think you're a very attractive man, and I aspire to be just like you one day nice
Just kidding you fucking Virginia
So
Disgusting. I hate this so much whatever
Yeah, read a nice comment on YouTube and like oh, this is so nice finally like a really nice comment
I haven't seen those in days literally years
I can't remember the last time I didn't go and send something nice in general with my name regarded to it and then you and
You keep reading in this like by the way, check out my channel in like god, dammit
My couch is hairy. Even what excuse me Mike who cheese hair even what say that again?
Mike who cheese hearing
It's time to stop please. I don't know. I don't know. I I literally don't know anything. I
Don't know what's happening Oh someone wrote it. Oh
My god
Oh God, it's not funny this is so childish and stupid but also it's hilarious and I love it
Dr. Murphy again
Sook undies, don't do it. Don't do it. Dr. Murphy, please. No, don't answer going to
See those Deez Nuts
I really appreciate the people
Taking the time out of their day just for that. One moment just for that one moment of epic trolling. That's it
That's all the time we had for today streams fails epic trolls if you're an epic troll stirrers
Leave a like just so I know if you are and also check out mercs link description
I think you will like it very much and now I'm gonna go and explored Nihon everyone
Bye. Bye
Tuber simulator. It's now so relevant that it's got a brand new minigame
crania
drop the crane and get fresh items only available in the washing machine like game and you say there's more of course there is
New knowledge perks new quests and new picks links and legs guys
length